well the rating system is designed as a
tool to give parents information so they
can then help their children make
decisions about what movies to see or
not it is not a form of censorship we
don't tell people what they can produce
but we will rate movies based upon what
we think average parents would think
that movie ought to be in terms of
whether the kids should be able to go to
it in a restricted way or in an
unrestricted way and we have parents who
work for us that rate the movies they
rate about 900 movies a year actually
some of these movies go directly to
theatrical movie house some of them go
directly to DVD but we will rate these
movies in order to give parents the
tools that they need to make the
decisions about whether the kids ought
to go to the movies or now now that
doesn't mean that necessarily the people
think that every movie is rated the
right way nor does it necessarily mean
that American people think that the
movies maybe going too far in one
direction or another with respect to
violence or sex or other kinds of things
but in this country we have this rating
system to not only get parents the
information but underlying it all is to
preserve free speech to prevent
censorship because before the rating
system we had ratings boards all over
the country many counties had them and
they would basically operate as
full-scale censorship operations they
would prevent movies from being shown
fortunately those days are over the
entertainment community I think does
have some obligation because our work
product goes out around the world and
does reflect on American values I think
that's one of the reasons why there's
such an enormous diversity of content
you know you'll see big blockbusters you
know like transformers or harry
potter.pirates of the caribbean that are
really liked almost everywhere you will
see edgier movies that might stretch the
limit on sex or violence you'll see a
fair amount of ultra violent movies that
i think there are some parent
concerns about some of these shows
you'll see very serious low-budget
movies as well so I I do think that when
you look at the whole category of movies
that are out there I think that the
product is diversified and frankly
highly competent professional well on
the negative side I'd say piracy remains
the dagger in the heart of this business
and with technology it's becoming easier
and easier to copy stuff but in and
particularly on the web uploaded
downloaded replicated do all sorts of
things so that that's something that
we're just it's a constantly a big
problem that looms over our heads and we
make at times some progress and then
times we fall back a bit you know but in
terms of the other thing I think the
most important thing we can do for this
business is the same as what we've done
for a lot of years which is to have
talented creative people who can write
and read the language of film and we we
have a reservoir of people out there who
have the ability to actually do it and
and I mean I think the money will come I
think the productions will come we will
never end piracy or I like to call it
theft piracy is Johnny Depp in Pirates
of the Caribbean it's a glamorous thing
but we will never end it but we our goal
is to stay ahead of it the biggest
challenge I think we have is to rate as
a generation of young people around the
world who may not think that downloading
a movie illegally or buying a DVD on the
streets or Street or related things is
wrong or violates the law and is trying
to make sure that our educational
institutions do a better job of teaching
people about the value of intellectual
property
you